hello everybody my name is markiplier
and I'm here with Bob and Wade and we
might be in some trouble here because Oh
something lurking out in the woods
that's trying to kill us right Bob and
Wade that's what I've been taught out
there yes there's something out there
but we need to go and get the pages for
this is slender minecraft wait a minute
oh wait seriously seriously Wade wait
seriously I'm over here
seriously wait okay so obviously we have
been stricken blind and we can't see
very far because it's an imperceptible
night eternally darkening our vision and
so that we cannot see in stuff so we
need to walk very carefully very
carefully towards some direction that's
unified Bob seriously Bob Bob seriously
okay thank you Bob that's a real creep
ah okay so yes we're flying sound what
the crap oh man whoa what the heck huh
what what Oh what is that what is that
oh no I always do that
I said it first no I said it first uh
okay so there's something that's let's
not go down let's not go down someone's
leads away I'm not gonna be it alright
follow me okay mommy I'll just Crouch
walk so you don't go to a the ginger
okay all right just don't we can't lose
each other because there's something
hiding in these woods something unreal
what's good wait if it shows up what do
we do cuz we're not gonna all run the
same way I don't know just try to run
the same way I mean I can't tell you
what to do in a panic situation we just
have to be brave leader is we all get
separated it's not my fault I'm gonna
try to follow you sure you ready go well
there's marks but wait thank you you
like this but you like it this but not
really
mmm I'd rather find the Enderman than
that but the ender but and I gotta get -
with her anus
yes we're bright behind you Bob we're
not gonna leave you I don't want to be
off of my own accessible I don't play
scary games I'm going over here okay all
right we gotta find a page how many
pages are there in this map I don't know
an infinite randomly generated supply
probably by the way what are you guys
drinking we haven't said that in the oil
o ly michelob ultra all right to camera
no sour oh my god why don't I just do oh
no it's ultra disgusting it's what that
stands for
Oh oh god damn it Wade stop being a dick
no I see an ender oh no no no okay wait
we're here he's being a douche mark
doesn't like be easy right was he being
a dick or a douche he was being a douche
the cool oh oh oh
where'd you guys it really cleans it no
couponing all night long yeah we were
kaput you want to play that game Bob now
oh do you want to play the ketubah team
Kevin Kevin Kevin hey whoa whoa we found
something we saw something what the hell
is their page there's a monster spawner
inside Wow it'll swim right this way
this way this way I'm following you I'm
following it this way this way they
spawn you that's a bad place to be
that's a bad thing
stop it so with me yeah we're with you
spy this one okay we got your back man
got your back
we're gonna cut through these trees here
I'm gonna cross walk again okay good all
right I think we're safe safe distance
say for now no weird sounds or get on
offense what's all this
oh why is there water on the other side
of this fence I don't know hey maybe
it's a boundary no no we can go around
it because right here I don't want to
jump down there this isn't very
unsettling with the Minecraft music in
the background
where are you bro I'm gonna turn off the
minecraft musics cuz
oh no where are you guys wait you're on
a dog go in the water you'll run in a
dock I'm in the water oh hello hello
okay there's got to be a page around
here somewhere
this seems like something that would
have a page
Oh their stuff let's go into the water
let's see if you have something like go
too far away from the water just kind of
I got idea doc oh wait what the whoa
what you thought what'd you find
I found a house over here to the right
yeah a small house
I heard that where is it oh here it is
yeah hi
Wow well I don't see any pages though
it's to the right in the water here I'll
come get you wait don't leave me over
here moving the water in the water this
way I'm so scared of the load those are
cute cuz I'm a big baby
I hear I hear right here hi mister you
are to go huh what do you mean you know
since this is minecraft and not just
slender I have an idea I'm gonna take
these doors with us really I'm I'm man I
don't like this I'm forgot yeah yeah I
got you I got ya I don't you sure I
think you spelled it wrong cuz you just
look like do I just have Enderman over
ahead yes did you type slash D space
player haha
yep that's I don't you don't type flare
yeah here let me show you you look like
oh god those those bed known better than
if I'd have been in intervene I plan
that from the beginning
alright alright onward okay I'm doors we
didn't find a page but I guess there
wasn't one of that location did you go
in the basement no I didn't know there
was one crafting whoa whoa why nothing
in there whoa whoa H on the on this the
frame is that count as a page wait where
right here where I'm standing
yeah that counts get it oh why why why
why would you punch it well I got it now
okay I've got I've got one I've got a
paper in my side and I've got two papers
why do I hear pistons there's a button
if you push it you get a paper okay
well that's handy all right well let's
go all right we got some pages how many
do you have Bob I've won I have two okay
so we've created one two okay so we have
four pages onward gentlemen we're doing
great happy heart there oh no crosswalk
some 100 follow me following I'm right
on top of you oh no aah what is that set
are we ok we're still together yeah tell
the other that's another one there's
another one there's another one where is
it I'll get it
where to go where to go where to go it's
to the right do the ride to the room why
do you just look like a a generic that
no aah oh no I'm almost dead guys slend
um on really really wait holy [ __ ]
there's an Enderman oh I got run away
where where run run off oh you say see
Bob I'm gonna die I looked right at it
is it coming for us this is what is this
oh it's wood we got to go over here guys
or just break it again yeah that's what
I'll hang on wait it's kind of what is
that is that the fence is this the
border is that the fence from before are
we about to break everything
probably let's go for it man just go for
it Matt battery so you probably don't
want to jump off of that Bob fine all
right let's go back it Hey mystical
force in the sky if you're gonna be like
that can I at least get some food yeah
me too please pretty please
dying a fear I don't also want to die of
hunger yeah okay wait where'd you guys
go home how you play so many damn horror
games you don't like the horror
I love the [ __ ] everybody likes the or
the hell or man we're going around the
boundary what is this [ __ ]
it's the boundary like a bunch of noobs
or we're winning I lost you guys yes the
one thing I told you print in a way wait
hang on I see wait what Bob stop for a
second I can see where weight is through
your head it's really me
yeah I can see his nametag okay Bob just
move our way move straight along like
move straight well let's no no not that
way you dick turn around
Bob stop moving okay no all of the fence
towards us you're here you're here okay
okay yes it was so weird I could see his
name play through your head okay anyway
so we still need to find a page but
they're not on the outskirts I guarantee
you that they're probably on the middle
in [ __ ] all right let's do it
thanks to the Crouch blog so as the
crotch wasp or scotch wah
crotch wah shut up wait I'm trying to
listen to Bob what you say Bob huh and
slender shut up wide what'd you say Bob
is that Enderman the slender or a see
like a is he just an Enderman in the
game I don't know
how am i sposta I don't think he's
programmed differently I think he's just
who he is I didn't see like our main
boss kind of guy might be let's punch
him and find out no we should totally
just gang up on him and punch the [ __ ]
out we could take him cuz we're awesome
like that right probably I'm so scared
dad I don't know why I'm leaning I don't
have no idea where we're going right now
as if we know anymore oh oh oh he's out
there where where I just heard him he
all keep grumble lettuce where he's
wrong up front of us he's right in front
us turn left turn left turn left this
ratio left are you sure oh he's right
there well go left idiot he's right
there
it just was just sneaking past him okay
big deal alright well that way go this
way hey I found a house the same house
no it's made of stone and stuff whoo
does it have a page probably there's an
anvil and furnaces here Oh
there's a basement that's my favorite
kind of place where's the basement down
here down where over here okay
redstone torches down here I'm so Aires
a page hey I got two pages can you get
any more I got two pages all right I got
three now somehow I don't know how I'm
getting these pages are you getting
extra pages is it so dark wait I just
got four pages now okay how are you
doing that um I'm going to sleep
screw you guys I'm sleeping yeah you do
sure you go find some while ago I woke
up again what's over here
oh this is an exit okay okay so we found
how many do we have in total I have to
wait I have to have four okay so we have
eight pages that's how many you need it
in the Slenderman game dude we've won I
guess we win how do I won we brought
cheated a bit come on over here look at
this I mean I'm up I'm gonna run off I'm
gonna run off ah man oh wait was that
you I'd mark we're not real hundred oh
where where it hit me unless I was way
just punching me like a dick that was
Wade punching me like a dick cuz he's
quiet you know that's why oh by out I'm
in the haha count ah there we go
wait death now he's off on his own ha ha
ha ha I've got the torch let's go Wade
give us a play-by-play of your horrible
situation alone in the woods it's dark
still more pages to collect oh ok really
that's all you have to say wait it's
dark you are the worst kind of youtuber
you are the worst
whoa I don't want you here
I didn't punch you you wait you got her
I got her yeah oh no I don't know what's
going on in here oh we've been to the
monster spawner
damn it okay I think
he's this way this time I think we need
to split up Bob I found an open field
all right I'm outta here
all right I'm gonna run this way if we
run into anything scream your head off
and then don't bring it to any of us and
if I find Wade I'm gonna get you Wade
I'm gonna get you huh I found the fence
but there's nothing on or around it
oh this is the stupid docks stupid docks
docks are for kids
ha ha ha Oh Bob did you find something
cow why why disguised us an Enderman
yeah I am is a blank player ha ha ha I
know I wanted to do that again [ __ ] why
did you attack me then cuz I didn't know
what you were I was dick uh never mind
i'ma stay like a god I heard it you
heard what I heard the end of it
I'm by the monster spawner we were just
there oh no I'm coming back for you
watch out for Enderman ha ha ha Oh help
me Wade no one can help you now Wade are
you still by the monster spawner no I
left where'd you go I'm running back
toward it watch out for the that injure
me what I hear it are there multiple
Enderman on this map I would believe it
uh uh wait where'd you go
all right Bob that's how I cry that's
how I cry right Bob wait where'd you go
wait where'd you go wake up I don't know
about a fence and then up back toward
the monster spawner well I'm waiting
here by the monster spawner if you guys
I don't know how to get back to it fine
then I'm gonna find you the Enderman is
coming for you guys the Enderman is
gonna find you huh yes sir
oh this sucks Oh No the mob spawner you
ha I don't wear anymore now the Enderman
is coming for you oh oh damn it every
time I get back to the monster spawner
you guys leave you go shut about you Bob
were together no we split up why cuz we
wanted to kill you Wade
you're killing me tell you I was just
trying to win how do you we don't know
how to win though we haven't found
anything else find all the page thing
yeah but have you found anything yet I
know the Enderman is looking and the
Enderman is not finding I need to drink
more excuse me
aha I don't know if I need to drink more
I don't think that's the surround the
boundary again yeah I found that earlier
earlier
haha well now I'm trying to find you
guys where the hell are you know wetter
no I'm wandering around toward the
middle oh I found a new building a new
building yes I found a pond it's like a
prison or something what is this
wait did you was it the same pond we
were at before Wade no this is a
different one oh no am i trapped on top
of the Bob duck okay you're right Bob
you're right ow yeah I'm okay they're
not look at a jail house or some stuff
oh this place is tiny there's nothing to
there's whoa whoa what the I'll whack up
oh oh my god oh this is why our doors
opening around me ah I got another page
did you really where were you why our
doors opening around me
cuz marks a dick hahaha I wish I knew
where you guys were Oh where'd you go
Bob
where'd you go are you still in the
building I mean are you still in the
building
deopt voice wise Bob oh man
I was called guy says haha am i just a
guy named Enderman still are you around
me yeah I haven't seen you yet where are
you oh okay
you don't see me oh crap I found the
real one now where are you help
yeah oh that's the jail cell oh my god
oh god you're nowhere near me are you
hmm
beware the doors opening hmm oh man I
found the boundary again are you guys
actually near or something
we're in less deal or water hang on
oh I lost my disguise yeah man I was
literally disguise you guys were never
gonna find me I was literally inches
from your face Bob when you really yeah
I was right in front of you
what were you I don't know I must have
been invisible eyes or something I found
a fence there's lots of fence yeah sound
like a stone fence like a cobblestone
looking fence
oh is it on top of the building cuz
that's where I just was I just got pages
okay good you said last of a page basis
are we up to now
yeah a magical server how many more
pages do we need whoa whoa where did I
go
three more hey Marv
huh I still can't believe my disguise
wasn't working
nope you look like Bob whoa ow who hit
me who hit me who's everybody
a portrait jo ah who's anybody why that
you wait up
whoa I don't know where you are whoa
whoa whoa whoa Wow what was the point in
coming here
what oh I hear you walking around
stranger in the darkness where are you
Bob Bob wait wait was that you was
actually no I didn't hit you I didn't
hit you can you see me can you see me
yeah I can see okay yeah I didn't hit
you something was enemy well just hit us
I don't know but now I can find the rest
of the stuff I've got five pages that
don't know where I'm at I've got six
pages I suck and I'm gonna try to find
something else here it's got to be
something we can do
OOP OOP OOP
was that okay we're what do you guys buy
right now your mother I'm not with him I
left I'm out of here
okay I'm back at the jailhouse thingy
I'm on top of some Hill with the page
from in there ah I thought you did
well yeah but I think we each get one I
tried to push the button I may have
gotten a page I don't know I have no
idea I'm just trying to find the last
thing somewhere ah I got parted what
where's this farm come from
I found a farm apparently cuz they all
were gone now aha got the rest of the
pages I think did we do it did we win
did we won I don't know I don't know
where this farm even is that you're
talking about I never ran across I heard
an explosion on place
hahaha okay cool beans I've got eight
pages now how many more do we need
magical sky god I've got six I didn't
ask you this what is this crap den and
crap what is this one last page ah man
Oh what is happening to you Bob
I don't know something horrible how did
my creepers do you guys remember that
stone brick building we're mark laid in
the bed yeah where I am I have no idea
where that is I found some ruins oh no
damn it
hahaha we got it I got the his badge I
think I'm gonna die I'm gonna die I'm
gonna die I'm gonna die hey I got the
last page
hahaha down railroad what the hell is
this then I did it did I did it I think
I did it
you live for now huh
was that good I've got seven paint now
I've got eight page I've got an extra
page I don't know where was that was
that it did did we one
dude are one why why me win on Duke wait
there's the winner well that's a rather
unceremoniously blow this whole place
out this let's blow everything up Tom
ate some I TNT everywhere turn
everything into tears creeper just
everything into TNT let's end this
episode off with a bang I think not
winners wrapped in hell what is this oh
yeah who is the winner who turned the
night yeah hey where are you guys now
cuz my blindness was cured wait hahaha I
just wait wait goes to troll you all
whoa hahaha every time you got hit that
was you the whole time it'll I knew it
was you why did you why didn't you get
to be slender how stupid I was stupid
she blessed me you wanted a yeah sure
and left me I did not kill anyone
to be clear that's why I smack you once
mom yeah that's true okay well I was
boring as [ __ ] God we did that oh boy
that was fun fun fun on a born ass don't
know you're talking to me you know this
one and oh my god what's happening is
more like it oh is it blowing up I just
froze grab is blowing up show stir this
what in the heck well I hear explosions
I don't even hear anything I just see
tea and tea I see a TNT I've got no
frames per second so yeah hey oh I see
some flashing wait I do have some boy no
I give me my gosh whoa whoa whoa whoa
whoa we're back let's just crash the
server okay maybe not that much TNT
magical sky god I'm gonna still frozen
but anyway you know a lot of people have
suggested to me about this minecraft
Slender map and now that I've actually
played it I can pretty much say that
it's a new worst slender game I've ever
played in my life that suck so much ass
I can't even believe it well you guys
have fun night
the server time oh I'm still on it
that's good right there's still random
bits of tnt floating around everywhere
oh my gosh so anyway I guess that's it
for this episode if you guys want to
play the Slender map try something else
because yeah yeah let's do have an
awesome friend like me who will slender
for you yeah I well I was like slender
for two seconds trying to hunt Bob but
being invisible isn't great Slenderman
oh I blew up I died okay so anyway thank
you all so much for watching Wade has a
youtube channel go check it out bob has
a Twitter that he likes to be followed
on and I have a YouTube channel that you
already know about so thank you all so
much for watching click the annotation
for more videos that we've done and as
always we will
you in the next video bye guys
but what
Oh
I've no way out of here